hello and welcome to intelligent squared
with me Carl Miller uh we're calling
here in London of course on May the 24th
uh and I'm excited really excited to
introduce I guess today Darren ASA
mogloo he's an acclaimed Economist he's
taught as a professor in the
Massachusetts institute for technology
since 1993 and is the author of
best-selling books including why Nations
fail and the narrow Corridor his new
book which we're discussing today is
called power and progress our
thousand-year-old struggle over
technology and prosperity Darren thanks
so much for coming thanks Kyle it's
great to be here all right so um let's
start with the um overall idea perhaps
that you're trying to kill with the book
tell us about the the kind of uh the the
bandwagon of of progress and why that's
wrong yeah so let me actually be step
take back take one step back
what we are in some sense attacking is a
deep rooted techno optimism
which claims that
technology by its nature is always good
for Humanity
as a pre-ordained essentially definitive
path
upon which we are bound to progress
unless we somehow block it
and if you put these two together you
arrive to A world view in which
there may be transition costs some
people may suffer temporarily but
ultimately we're all going to benefit
whatever happens so long as we are
working towards technological progress
and this is what we want to push against
and we want to push against that because
a
We Believe based on history and
economics that there are many ways in
which you can use technologies that do
not generate these broad-based benefits
and second
that the path of technology is very
malleable there's a lot of choice which
specific Direction you develop it with
very different distributional
consequences and the bandwagon of
progress is essentially the name we give
to the body of work in economics that is
part of this argument which says you
know as long as technology improves your
capabilities to produce goods and
services it's going to increase wages
so it is sort of a happy story that
labor demand
and firm's desire to increase their
scale are sufficient forces to translate
some of the technological improvements
into benefits for workers and we
question that how how old is this
argument because of course like I think
those of us that are living through the
current Revolution might trace it back
to the kind of Bay Area Libertarians and
a certain Vision coming from Silicon
Valley but is this a kind of argument
which we've always been told as as a as
a culture and as a society
um has stretching back through the
various revolutions which have
previously previously swept through and
the way that we live yes and yes
in a broad way
humans live in communities
and they have to coordinate they have to
follow
some sort of common path
and so they have to be convinced
of accepting certain Arrangements
so the argument that whatever is being
chosen by leaders is for the common good
I think is as old as humanity and
sometimes it is
sometimes when a band of
hunter-gatherers choose
to go north rather than South that could
in fact be exactly what they need to do
and a leader may be the one who
catalyzes that decision but in many many
places especially since the beginning of
settled agricultures leaders have also
told us
toil harder and that's good for society
you're going to get your reward in the
other world or this is your station in
life but but the specific version of the
productivity bandwagon techno optimism
actually you start seeing that in a very
clear version for example in the middle
starting in the middle of the 18th
century with the British Industrial
Revolution so ideas that technological
progress will generate benefits then
those will start becoming broadly shared
through the labor market through
improvements in quality and product
variety you see that already in some of
the you know forerunners of modern
economics who were amazingly
revolutionary in their way of thinking
you know Adam Smith how could I disagree
with his super amazing intellectual
leadership I'm an economist but Adam
Smith was a firm believer in the
productivity bandwagon he did not want
to entertain the idea that technological
improvements could for example create
joblessness and David Ricardo by the way
who is perhaps the second most important
Economist after Adam Smith also started
there he was a member of parliament as
you know he made speeches to Parliament
saying Machinery will not create
unemployment but then he changed his
mind and then he started he added a
chapter to his uh principles of
economics saying you know actually I'm
worried about new Machinery creating
joblessness and and and so how to turn
turn around on that so so there's
there's been a debate on this all the
time but when economists came back to it
at the beginning of the 20th century it
was again the more optimistic take that
was uh was the one that was adopted so
does capital
and the elites that wield it do they
always win from these revolutions
no
no uh I mean first of all there are many
disruptions
inflation
world wars
they led to Big losses to Capital owners
in the 20th century
but the reason why I hesitated
is actually
if you find a path of technology that is
more pro-human more useful for workers
we can talk more about what that is in a
second but actually firms benefit from
that
the best example for that I would say is
the Social Democratic equilibrium that
emerged in Sweden after you know the
Great Depression and uh uh sort of the
the victory of the Swedish Workers Party
in the 1932 election that led to a
corporatist model
that was quite Cooperative between
capital and labor labor had very strong
bargaining power
High wages social welfare programs but
at the same time that whole system was
very encouraging for businesses to
invest in education and technology so in
in in in in in in in in machinery and
Technology choose a path of technology
that was both good for their competition
and Export markets but at the same time
help workers and businesses made a lot
of profits out of that so there's a path
that's actually good for Capital out of
this as well but you know in the US for
example over the last four and a half
decades
many business
managers and many
capital
owners or you know the richest sort of
people who control corporations have
gone much more into a strategy that
squeezes labor heart tries to reduce
labor costs automation surveillance
again that can generate profits for
Capital but it's not the only thing that
generates capital I gave a very long
answer to this because I I don't want to
create the impression that there is a
mortal conflict between capital and
labor
I think
creating the right type of technological
path can be beneficial for Capital as
well well Darren we I know lots of
people listen to this are going to be
very anxious possibly
um maybe excited as well about the
current Revolution we're living through
of course artificial intelligence and
you can't move for someone asking chat
gbt something at the moment so we're of
course going to get to that but I know
in the book you Tracer a much longer
threat looking at the Revolutions of the
past and what they can teach us about a
current moment and I think you know as a
as a kind of a one-time historian myself
that is an important thing for us also
to consider and to dwell on just for a
moment to consider the time we live in
now so tell us about the Panama Canal
and and the lessons that that the that
that has for us around the kind of power
of persuasion perhaps of gender setting
and Powerful Visions yeah I mean
absolutely I think if you look at
history especially you know of course
history is there to be interpreted to
some degree so the lenses through which
you look at them is important but if you
look at it through these lenses of
people
acting as technological leader
Visionaries
articulating the common good and and
optimism about the future of technology
you see so many examples of it and
you see successful applications and you
see disastrous ones and the Panama Canal
is very important because it is the it's
a big project of Ferdinand de lesseps
who was
you know the epitomization of the Techno
optimism of the second half of the 19th
century and he was very successful
because he brought exactly that Vision a
belief in technology belief in trade
small people will contribute Capital
build a big public infrastructure and
that's going to spearhead trade between
east and west and it's going to open up
uh Oceanic route and technology is going
to come to make things that appeared in
feasible feasible that was exactly his
stick for the Suez Canal and people were
skeptical he pushed he was very skillful
in building coalitions cajoling people
getting uh French investors on board
getting Egyptians
ruler on board and he succeeded all his
techno optimism paid off when people
said no you cannot build a canal at the
sea level without the locks in Suez he
said no we'll find a way of working out
the technology and he turned out to be
right
but that's the problem
that success made him even more
hubristic
and that success was always a success
from his own point of view for example
he didn't care about course laborers in
in in Egypt who were not beneficiaries
of the Suez Canal and he brought the
same set of blinders the same confidence
the same rhetoric the same techno
optimism to the Panama Canal where
conditions were very different and it
was a complete disaster he went in
thinking he could do exactly the same
but the in two ways
the Panama was very different first of
all there was no way you could build a
canal without locks without doing a much
much bigger scale project and second the
local conditions especially yellow fever
malaria in the rainy season meant that
the type of heavy labor based approach
wouldn't be feasible as a result 22 000
plus people died thousands of the best
Engineers from France perished
millions of millions of dollars
equivalent of money was lost by many
many small investors
you know it was a complete disaster
because he was approaching it with the
same set of blinders that had become
more confident because of his earlier
successes see what optimism then the
Panama Canal proves is is something
which can lead us in the wrong direction
technologically is the next historical
import you look at settled agriculture
evidence of even when the revolution
might pay off in terms of productivity
increases that might not be a good thing
for society and for most of us to live
within it or I would say it's not enough
to create broad-based Prosperity so the
let's just you know to keep it brief
let's just take one formative
technological breakthrough in the
Medieval Era uh water Mills and then
windmills that both really completely
revolutionized a lot of the production
but you know great
amazing improvements in labor
productivity amazing improvements in
what we could do uh but they weren't
enough to increase the living conditions
of
the majority of the population who are
working as farming workers why because
those workers had no organization they
were still tied by feudal or servile
relations there was no competition
windmills for example were completely
monopolized by abbots and uh and a very
small group of uh Noble land older
holders no competition
actually in many ways coercive relations
intensified and that's not the kind of
institutional structure that's
sufficient to generate broad-based
prosperity
when have we Darren most successfully
kind of pushed back I guess against the
kind of
um
collectivizing kind of impulses of these
revolutions you know and either I I
guess through either social or
institutional reform either forced the
benefits to become more widely
distributed or Force technology to be
developed in a certain direction which
led to more widely distributed outcomes
yeah I think two examples are really
inspiring and very well understood by
now one is what started happening in the
UK for instance in the second half of
the 19th century and the second is what
happened in throughout the
industrialized world in the three three
and a half decades after World War II in
both cases at least Simon Johnson and my
interpretation is
very much consistent with our conceptual
framework you had the two pillars
of broad-based prosperity shared
Prosperity one a technology that was
worker friendly it wasn't just
automating work it was creating new
tasks for workers it was helping workers
become more productive in their tasks
and second it was a bolstered by an
Institutional structure that created
bargaining power negotiation power for
workers so that they could not be
completely monitored uh hugely
disciplined course into a relationship
and they could ask for a fair share of
the Surplus that they created in the
second half of the 19th century this is
very telling because it is such a
contrast to what happened the previous
100 years the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution was a harsh time
for the working people
real incomes for workers by and large
did not increase much for about 100
years their working hours intensify
their working conditions worsen their
living conditions worsens and infested
very unhealthy very crowded cities so
the first 100 Years of the Industrial
Revolution produced very little benefit
for the working people why did that
change in the second half democracy
Civil Service becoming more interested
in cleaning up cities and providing
Public Services education and trade
unions
so trade unions became legal things like
Master servant acts became
abolished in the 1870s and so that
created the bargaining power together
with that both because of the
Technologies coming from the United
States because of the push from unions
and other factors technologies that
started increasing workers capabilities
in new manufacturing tasks and white
color tasks started spreading as well
and you see exactly the same factors in
the decades after World War II
there was a lot of automation but
automation was not the only thing that
technology did lots of new tasks lots of
new activities for workers new
Industries and bolstered by a strong
labor movement and a democratic process
and those two pillars
I think are really critical for
understanding these processes and
they're dismantling is also very
important for understanding what went on
after the 1980s
right
artificial intelligence we've arrived
so what historical Echoes when you sit
back and you consider the moment we're
living through now what are the
historical Echoes that you think are
most poignant or most important for us
to remember you know do you see the the
powerful visions of the Panama Canal do
you see the prospect of workers losing
out like some of the Agricultural forms
do you see either the prospect or the
reality of institutional reform like
post-world War II reconstruction what
are the big ideas or moments of the past
you think that we need to remember all
of the above well that was a that's a
nice short answer but let me let me see
two things and then we can do first of
all I said 1980s because
I think we cannot understand the current
moment in isolation of how we've used
digital Technologies over the last 40
years AI is different
but it is a continuation of the digital
Revolution that started sometime in the
1970s and it really came into fruition
in the 1980s now some people will
criticize me and say AI is completely
different from previous computers and we
can debate that but there is actually a
lot of continuity in terms of what AI is
being used and how it's being processed
that's the first thing so we'll talk
about digital Technologies but second
yes if you want to see historical
parallels
the lessepsis Panama hubris
Jeremy bentham's panopticon idea of
monitoring workers monitoring schools
monitoring hospitals
the medieval separation of Elites to
non-elites the two-tiered society
the early stages of the British
Industrial Revolution where
you know there was this idea that
meritocratically the innovators the
entrepreneurs would benefit and the lazy
not so productive people could be left
behind all of these plus standard oils
monopolization of Key Resources all of
them bunched into one I think we get AI
I I know you make much in your book of
the idea that actually the directions
that technology goes in is a choice that
we make and and it can go in One
Direction it can go in another and that
the current directions in AI are around
Automation and the replacement of
workers and how that might you know have
all kinds of deleterious and harmful
consequences for society
beginning to think about Solutions and
responses now what do you do about that
kind of thing because it often feels
like this idea of permissionless
innovation you know the idea that a tiny
number of elite technologists you know
um with access to vast reserves of
capital and Talon kind of make these
decisions themselves about about which
direction they want to go and then they
made that decision around automation how
do we people listening to this policy
makers may be right as academics what do
we do about that seemingly kind of
Fairly essential nature of of the way
that technology development actually
works well I think those are exactly the
right questions